UP NOT WINNING, THE PRESIDENT
CARRY AROUND HERE.
>> Sean: ED HENRY, THANK YOU.
JOINING IS NOW THE BRAND-NEW
BROKE THE
BOOK, FORMER PRESIDENT VINCENTE
FOX FEARED HOW ARE YOU?
WE'VE HAD SOME FIGHTS BEFORE.
WHEN YOU WERE PRESIDENT, IN THE
YEAR 2002, YOU DEPORTED, YOU
KICKED OUT OF YOUR COUNTRY
140,000 PEOPLE THAT ENTERED
MEXICO ILLEGALLY -- FROM
YOU THREW THEM OUT, AND YOU SAY
WE DO THAT WHERE OUR RACIST AND
THIS IS UNFAIR AND UNKIND AND
UNJUST.
YOU DID THIS VERY THING YOU
DON'T WANT US TO DO.
>> THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I AGREE
WITH YOU 100%.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
BORDERS MUST BE SECURE, AND
BORDERS MUST BE SAFE, AND WE
MUST KEEP ORDER LIKE WE TRY TO
DO WITH PRESIDENT BUSH AND
SENATOR McCAIN AND
SENATOR KENNEDY.
WE PUT TOGETHER A BILL THAT WAS
WALL STUPID?
WHY DID YOU GIVE -- TELL TRUMP
WHY IF THE WALL IS GOOD, WHY DO
YOU SAY BUILD THE WALL LIKE
TRUMP SAID WITH A DOOR?
WE COULD LET OUR FRIENDS IN, BUT
NOT THE DRUG DEALERS.
>> WE ARE NOT WAR.
IT IS GOOD IF YOU WANT TO BUILD
BUT MEXICO IS NOT PLAYING FOR
THAT WALL.
THAT'S A STUPID IDEA.
I THINK HE'S PART TWO MARCUS
SMART.
IT'S A WIN-WIN SITUATION WE BOTH
BOOK.
LET'S MOVE AHEAD.
THIS BOOK IS NOT A GOOD BOOK
CONFRONT.
IT'S REASONING IDEAS, PROPOSALS.
THAT'S WHERE YOU WILL READ
THERE.
>> Sean: FORGET ABOUT WHO PAYS
FOR IT FOR A MINUTE.
A WALL THAT AMERICA BUILDS ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
FORGET ABOUT THE PAYMENT.
IF WE BUILD A WALL, BUT I THINK
MEXICO -- I THINK WE SHOULD BE
BEST FRIENDS.
I THINK AMERICA AND CANADA
SHOULD BE BEST FRIENDS.
MEXICO, CANADA, AND THE
UNITED STATES TO ALL BE BEST
DISRESPECT THAT.
>> NOT AT ALL.
I WANT SECURITY.
I WORKED AT SIX YEARS WITH
PRESIDENT BUSH FOR THAT PURPOSE.
WE HAD A GOOD PARTNERSHIP FOR
PROSPERITY AND SECURITY.
WE CAME OUT WITH A THING THAT
CAN CURE HAD TO SECURITY.
I DO NOT HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
THEY CALLED MEXICANS CRIMINALS.
>> Sean: HE NEVER SAID ALL
MEXICANS.
HE SAID SOME.
BE FAIR.
SOME ARE MURDERERS.
AND THAT'S TRUE.
AND MADE HIS COUNTRY
COMPETITIVE.
>> Sean: YOU WANT THEM TO
BECOME CITIZENS.
HERE'S THE THING.
YOU AGREE AND THE RULE OF LAW.
YOUR THERE PRESIDENT.
IF YOU DON'T RESPECT AMERICAN
LAW AND YOU COME HERE ILLEGALLY,
THEN YOU DO NOT RESPECT OUR --
WAIT A MINUTE.
ALL THESE PEOPLE WANT TO COME
IN.
RESPECT OUR LAWS.
>> THIS IS NOT THE UNITED STATES
ITS FOUNDING FATHERS.
>> Sean: ABSOLUTELY IS.
ALL FOUR OF MY GRANDPARENTS CAME
FROM IRELAND, AND THEY CAME
THROUGH ELLIS ISLAND, THEY
DIDN'T HAVE ANY MONEY, THEY WERE
BROKE, AND THEY CAME HERE
LEGALLY.
ALL WE ARE SAYING, WE WILL BE
GOOD NEIGHBORS.
YOU HAVE TO RESPECT OUR BORDER.
RESPECT OUR LAW.
>> THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO COME
UP WITH WISE, BRIGHT IDEAS, AND
NOT THIS ANYMORE.
THAT DOESN'T HELP THE IMAGE OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Sean: WHY DO YOU CALL THE
PRESIDENT STUPID?
HE CAN GO TO HELL?
YOU PUT YOUR MIDDLE FINGER UP.
YOU SAY HE'S AN IDIOT.
WHY DO YOU SAY ALL OF THAT?
I INVITED HIM TO COME.
>> Sean: HE CAME TO MEXICO.
>> THAT WAS A MISTAKE BECAUSE --
>> Sean: WHY WAS IT A MISTAKE?
>> HE SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN, BUT
THAT'S ANOTHER ISSUE.
>> Sean: IF THE AMERICAN
>> Sean: 40 SOME ODD PERCENT.
THAT'S HOW OUR SYSTEM WORKS BUT
HOW MANY PEOPLE VOTED FOR YOU?
>> FOR ME?
46%.
>> Sean: YOU DIDN'T HAVE A
MAJORITY EITHER.
>> I DIDN'T GO AGAINST
OPPOSITION.
I TRY TO UNITE.
>> Sean: LET'S END THIS ON A
GOOD NOTE.
YOU WERE A LOT CALMER THIS TIME
THAN THE LAST TIME WE HAD A BIG
FIGHT.
I WOULD SAY, WE NEED BORDERS TO
PROTECT OUR COUNTRY.
>> AGREED APPEARED TO BE WHAT I
WOULD SAY, AT THE PRESIDENT IS
RIGHT.
>> YOU DON'T NEED WALLS, YOU
NEED BORDERS.
>> IS A WASTE OF MONEY.
>> Sean: LET US DECIDE WHAT WE
ARE GOING TO DO.
WE WILL BUILD THE WALL WITH A
FRIENDS.
BUT AMERICA HAS THE RIGHT NOT TO
LET PEOPLE ENTER HERE ILLEGALLY.
>> WHO WILL PAY FOR THAT WALL
AND DOOR?
>> Sean: HOPEFULLY MEXICO AND
NOT THE UNITED STATES.
>> U.S. TAXPAYERS AND NOBODY
ELSE.
>> Sean: THE WALL IS FILLED
SPEAK IT WITH A BIG DOOR?
>> WITH A DOOR THAT PEOPLE COME
LEGALLY.
>> I DON'T MIND THE WALL BEING
BUILT, I'M JUST TRYING TO ADVISE
AMERICAN CITIZENS, DON'T MAKE